one of the things that I think that's
was I think it seems particularly
painful since you resigned and not just
for you but I just think for people that
believe in the causes that you're
fighting for is that you were in the
opinion of many people including myself
a really effective hard-working senator
now you're on the sidelines and we were
having hearings that are affecting the
course of our republic and you were very
effective in hearings you really were I
mean when you when you were questioning
Jeff Sessions you ended up getting him
to recuse himself which ended up
changing the course of the entire
Russian vesti he lied to me and he lied
to you specifically in what way I mean I
know that I baby people know but I just
want to bring everyone I was basically
asking him if anybody on your campaign
on the Trump campaign had met with
Russians would you recuse yourself ins
because you and he said well I know I
haven't met with any Russians and he met
with the Ambassador from Russia three
times right
during that including at the Republican
convention right and including in his
office and you know he it wasn't like I
don't remember meeting him right so he
was almost if you read the malla report
he was almost charged with perjury but
he said that he his he was confused
his defy his defense was that you your
question confused him yes
seems like a pretty straightforward
question well you know he is then was
the number one law enforcement officer
in the country yeah and I confused him
[Laughter]
well I think that speaks of my effective
yes yeah for one yeah I'm getting
confused now you're just I don't know
who I am or where I am you is it what's
it like now to be you and you're
watching these hearings these what could
end up being impeachment hearings where
I think you'd be a very effective
question if you find yourself yelling at
the screen because you have an idea for
the right question and the person on the
screen whether there is not asking that
question yes yes that happens sometimes
I have emailed my colleagues during a
hearing and said this might be good
mm-hm and you know it is very
frustrating and now I mean listen
everyone's frustrated by this this time
in our country's history and what had
what's happened the last couple days is
unbelievable we have a president we've
seen we've seen what he's had basically
telling a foreign leader you're not
gonna get what you need in terms of
tanks unless you dig up dirt about my
opponent I mean this is having a foreign
country interfere in our elections which
sounds familiar
mm-hmm you know and you would think that
after spending the last two and a half
years defending himself against kind of
that charge that he wouldn't do
something like this and I don't know
what it is you remember like a couple
months ago he told George Stephanopoulos
Stephanopoulos asked him if you if
someone from foreign power came to you
with some dirt about your opponent would
you take it and he went yeah I think
everybody would
yeah and no everybody wouldn't in fact
there's a little bit of a precedent
there's a well Al Gore in 2000 the gore
campaign received george w bush's debate
book now that's pretty valuable too but
they didn't open it and they gave it to
the FBI because you're running for
president the united states right and we
want the president united states to be
someone that we can respect and I think
people it's hard for people right now
under this guy it really is just weird
why do you think Trump why do you think
they release the transcript why do you
think the White House released a
transcript because it to be I my
assumption was and I this is not my
world and I'm not smart in this area but
my overall assumption was they can
Stonewall anything they can just that
what that transcript will never come out
and the transcript is fairly damning why
would they release it very damning I
think Trump just thought like you know I
get away with this
you know what you know you can't bribe a
foreign power to get dirt about your
opponent oh come on
right you know when Stephanopoulos said
you can't you don't do that he said oh
everybody would do it
right so I'm sure he's just going like
oh come on
yeah and Angora he'd say well Gore lost
see you say I'm smarter than you yeah
yeah the smartest person in the world
yeah yeah and this one is I mean today
they got to the total House members will
vote to say they'll vote to impeach
right and you know the mullet report had
plenty in it believe me too
to do that just see it's number of
counts of obstruction of justice and and
it looks like Attorney General bar maybe
mess mixed up in this and on reporting
on when he reported on the Muller report
he didn't tell the truth right so it's
just an ugly time yeah I it's
interesting to be in late-night
television now a lot of my colleagues
who are really brilliant they're really
good at it they can they're very good at
making a lot of hay about this political
stuff and we do some of it but I have to
say I would I would rather do the green
car add these pays the Trump stuff just
makes me sad